ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
วันนี้ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ค่ะโคเรียงคะเดี๋ยวกูเขียนเองนะคะได้ค่ะ
ทุเรียนคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
อาทิตย์ค่ะวันอาทิตย์นะคะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 10 ค่ะ
วันที่ 10 เดือนอะไรเดือนเมษายนค่ะ
เดือนเมษายน
คู่ได้มีคำถามไหม
คำถามเดือนนี้เดือนเมษายนต่อไปต่อไปบีมี
คอสต์อะไรคะพ.ต.ต.
165 ค่ะแล้วปี
คศอะไรคะ
2022 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้ที่เราคุยกันอยู่กี่โมงแล้วคะครู
เอ๋
rov เวลา
11:00 น
21 นาที
[เพลง]
11:21 นาทีค่ะโคเรียมโอเคกูเห็นลบนะคะ
บุหรี่มได้ค่ะ
วันนี้เป็นยังไงบ้างคะ a ร้อนให้ที่คอนโด
มีร้อนมากเรียนร้อนมาก
แต่กูเรียนวันนี้ครูเอ๋มีอะไรอยากจะเล่า
ให้ฟัง
พระเอกจะเล่าอะไรคะกูอยากจะเล่าเกี่ยวกับ
ประเทศไทย
จะวัดเหมือนไหมอ่ะ
อ่า
อันนี้อันนี้เป็นอะไรคะคุณเรียมอันนี้
เป็น
แผนที่ประเทศไทยใช่ค่ะใช่ค่ะ
[เพลง]
อาหารที่ประเทศไทยใช่วันนี้ทำไมครูเอ๋ยัง
พูดเกี่ยวกับประเทศไทยหน้าอ๋อช่อประเทศ
ไทย
โอเคค่ะอันนี้ประเทศไทยนะคะอันนี้ประเทศ
ไทยยนะคะนักเรียน
เราก็อ่ากูเรียนรู้จักอันนี้ไหมคะรู้จัก
ส่งออกไหมคะ
จากค่ะ
ส่งออกเนี่ยต้องใช้อะไรคะทุเรียนอันนี้
เป็นอะไรคะ
เรือค่ะเก๋เป็นเรือนะคะเรือใหญ่ๆนะคะที่
เราเรียกว่าเรือขนส่งสินค้า
หนาเดี๋ยวคู๋ว่าวัดไหน
และเรือใหญ่แล้วก็บนเรือเนี่ยจะมีตู้
อ่ะตู้อะไรอยู่บนตัวค่ะ
ตู้คอนเทนเนอร์
นะคะมีตู้ตู้มากๆนะคะประเทศไทยเราเนี่ย
ค่ะครูเรียมมีส่งออกก็คือมีมีของมีของใน
ประเทศไทยเราก็ส่งออกไปญี่ปุ่น
เห็นไหมคะคุยเขียนเห็นค่ะส่งออกไปอ่ะจีน
ส่งออกไปยุโรป
ขอราคา
ไป
อเมริกานะคะมีของเนี้ยส่งออกไป
ต่างประเทศนะคะต่างประเทศก็คือไม่ใช่
ประเทศไทยเรามีของนะส่งออกไปต่างประเทศ
มากๆแล้วก็มีนำเข้าด้วยนะถ้าออกมาเรา
เรียกว่าส่งออกแต่ถ้าเข้าเนี่ยเราเรียก
ว่านำเข้านำข้าวให้
แม่นำเข้าแล้วก็ส่งออกซึ่งส่งออกเนี่ยอาจ
จะใช้เรือ
หรือเครื่องบินเน๊าะ
ไม่มีเรือมีเครื่องบินนะคะจะนำเข้าหรือ
ส่งออกนะคะ
วันนี้เนี่ยครูเอ๋จะให้ครูเรียมดู
ของที่ที่ไทยส่งออกต่างประเทศ
นกของที่คนไทยส่งออกต่างประเทศมีอะไรบ้าง
ค่ะครูเอ๋เดี๋ยวกูเอกขอแชร์สกรีนนะคะ
มุก
มาไหม
ค่ะ
ไก่เลยค่ะ
ก็เห็นได้ยินเสียงใจไก่ที่บ้าน
ไก่จะใว้ไก่ก็เป็นของเป็นอาหารที่คนไทย
ส่งออกไปต่างประเทศนะคะ
แต่ว่าว่าเอาอันนี้ก่อนค่ะที่ประเทศไทย
ส่งออกไปมากๆนะคะคุณเลี้ยงเห็นไหมคะเนี่ย
เห็นไหมค่ะเห็นค่ะ
อันนี้หน่อยครับพี่เขาข้ารู้
จักไหมคะ
คิดว่าเป็น
ยางพาราโอ้นี่คะในห่ายางพารา R ตัวนี้
ราคา
สักครู่นะคะ
อันนี้เป็นต้นยางนะคะแล้วก็เขากรีดตัวนี้
เป็นน้ำยางนะมองเห็นใช่ไหมคะมองเห็นน้ำ
ยางอันนี้เป็นต้นยางอายุต้นยางอันนี้น้ำ
ยาแล้วก็มาเป็นตัวนี้
อะไรคะเหว่ยยางแผ่นยางพารา
เขาก็เอาไปตากแล้วก็เป็นแผ่นๆนะคะอ่ะคู่
เรียมยางพาราเนี่ยเขาเอาไปทำอะไรทราบไหม
คะ
เรียงก็ไม่แน่ใจนะคะจะเรียงเคยได้ยินว่า
ที่นอนยางพารา
นายอะไรคะก็กำลังวาดอะไรรถ
รถอันเนี่ย
ล้อรถคู่เอกกำลังอยากกินต้มยำไก่
ค่ะเอ๋ลืมคิดว่าถ้าจะจับไก่เลี้ยงส่งออก
แล้วนะรู้ว่าส่งให้
ส่งในต่างประเทศเลย
ง่า
งั้นของที่ไทยส่งออกต่างประเทศมีมากๆจาก
คู่ a เอามาให้ดูนิดหน่อยนะคะก็อย่างคารา
นะคะยางพารา
ยางพาราก็เอามาทำอ่ะอะไรนะผู้เรียนบอกที่
นอนที่นอนค่ะ
ที่นอนเป็นแบบนี้
นอน
ที่นอนยางพารา
ใช่ค่ะอ่ะดีนะรอรถที่นอนนะคะนี่เป็นอย่าง
ที่หนึ่งที่คนไทยส่งออกส่งยางพารานะคะ
กลับไปค่ะ
[เพลง]
อะไร
อ่า
ส่งอะไรคะ
ขอเรียกสองอย่าง
สั้นๆน่ะพลอย
เอายาว
อัญมณี
วัน 4 ปัญญา
อัญมณีเราก็พลอยนะคะของไทยไทยจะมีตัวนี้
นะตัวนี้อ่ะตอนนี้ของกัมพูชาตัวตัวนี้มี
อาจจะมีตัวนี้อ่ะเราเรียกว่าอัญมณี
สัญญามันมี
ทั้งหมดอัญมณีชอบไหมคะชอบค่ะชอบสวย
มีหลายๆสีนะชายๆก็เป็นชื่อนะคะแต่มีชื่อ
ก็อย่างสีเขียวนี่ก็หยกนะคะสีแดงนี่
สีแดงอันนี้ก็โกลด์แมนสีน้ำเงินครูเรียน
รู้จักไหมคะเรียกว่าอะไร
ไม่รู้ค่ะใครรินเอาไพรีแปลไทยรนด์ซีนี้ก็
เป็น
กับทีม
กับทีมราคาโอเคแต่คลิปนี้เราพูดนิดหน่อย
นะอันเดียวมณีก็มีอันเดียวไม่มีบางอย่าง
ที่ไทยส่งออกค่ะใครส่งออกต่อไปนี่
กรูเองอย่าเพิ่งรู้คนไทยส่งอันนี้ออกต่าง
ประเทศด้วย
ไม่เคยเห็นมันคืออะไรค่ะกูเองมันคือ
อ่ะครึ่งเรียกเมล็ดพลาสติก
เมล็ดติดไทยวงแรก
เปิดคือเปิดเว็บไซต์แล้วอาหารคนไทยส่ง
อะไรออกขอส่งมาเล่นพลาสติกออกไปต่าง
ประเทศ
เอาไปค่ะโคเรียมเอาไปส่งออกอะไรคะ
เสื้อผ้า
เสื้อผ้าไทยส่งออกต่างประเทศนะ
next  in  Thailand อยู่ล่ะ
มีมีเสื้อผ้ามีรองเท้าอ่ะ
จะมีรองเท้าแต่อาจจะไม่ใช่เป็นแบรนด์เนม
ไทยแต่ทำในประเทศไทยแล้วก็ส่งออกแล้วก็มี
พวกเสื้อกันหนาวก็มีส่งออกเหมือนกันนะคะ
มีเสื้อผ้าถ่ายที่เราส่งออกนะคะแล้วก็มี
อันนี้ด้วย
เป็นอะไรคะของ
เป็นของใช้ในครัวนะคะของใช้ในครัวนิทำจาก
ไม้อันนี้ใช่ไหมคะอันนี้เป็นเขียงนี่เป็น
อะไรครับคุณเรียม
Time ชายค่ะอันนี้นะคะ
ขาด
ห่าค่ะได้จานก็ได้เนาะแล้วก็ตรงนี้นะคะ
ช้อนค่ะ
อันนี้รู้จักไหมเครื่อง
ขอไอเค้ากินอะไรที่นวดแป้งหรอคะได้เวลาทำ
อาหารฝรั่งน้องทำขนมหนวด
เห็นใช้
กินหมดแป้ง
ตอนนี้อะไรคะ
2 ตัวนี้อีกตะหลิวตะหลิวนะคะอันนี้ล่ะคะ
เค้าที่อะไรคะอ่าตะกร้อติ
ตีไข่ปีเค้กเวลาทำเค้กเนาะไม่ตีเราพูดว่า
ตะกร้อตีไข่
CK กะเค้กอย่างใช่ๆ R ทั้งหมดตรงนี้ค่ะ
เราเรียกว่าเป็น
เป็นผลิตภัณฑ์นะคะจากไม้นะคะผลิตภัณฑ์ก็
คือของแต่ของที่ทำจากไม้อาหารเนี้ยเขียง
ไม้ชามไม้นะคะอาจตะหลิวเนาะ
ตะหลิวไม้ถาดไม้จานไม้ถ้วยไม้นะคะช้อน
ช้อนตักข้าวที่ทำจากไม้อันนี้ก็มีที่ทำ
แล้วก็ส่งออกขายต่างประเทศ
ว้าวมีมีมีเขาเรียกว่าโรงงาน
เป็นแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะโรงงาน
โรงโรงงานทำอันนี้ค่ะอยู่อาจที่ชลบุรีที่
ใกล้ๆบ้านกูเอกก็มี 1 โรงงาน
ทำแล้วส่งต่างประเทศ
ไม่ได้ขายในประเทศไทยใช่ไหมไม่ได้ขายค่ะ
ส่งมีมีค่ะมีสีสันก็แตกต่างประเทศแล้วก็
ต้องส่งออกไปต่างประเทศค่ะ
[เพลง]
อันนี้ก็เป็นเครื่องมาเครดิตตะพันจากไม้
นะคะมีอันนึงกูเรียมนี่
เข้าไถ่ข่าวไทยใช่ค่ะก็ส่ง
ก็ส่งออกนะคะก็จะมีข้าวหลายๆอย่างนะคะ
ทั้งหมดตรงนี้แล้วว่าข้าวข้าวไทยเราก็ส่ง
ออกไปต่างประเทศนะคะก็ถ้าเป็นตัวนี้ก็
เป็นขอโทษค่ะวันนี้ก็จะเป็นเข้ากล้องเนาะ
อันนี้ก็เข้ากล้องเค้ากรองเข้ากล้องเข้า
กล้องเข้าเหนียว
อันนี้ข้าวอะไรคะคุณเรียว
เรียกเข้าเจ้าเขาเจ้านะคะเข้าเจ้าได้เข้า
สารได้
เข้าเจ้าเขาและก็ประเทศไทยก็ส่งข้าวออก
ต่างประเทศนะคะมีอะไรอีกไหมมาก
ผลไม้ก็ส่งออกค่ะครูเรียมลบผลไม้ที่ส่ง
ออกมีผลไม้อะไรบ้างคะครูเอ๋ก็มีอยากได้ไป
เลื่อนข้าวออกไปก่อนนะคะเคารพจะมีก่อน
มีทุเรียนนี้
เมื่อมา
ทุเรียนเหมือนไหม
กี่ทุเรียนเรียกว่า
ไปเอาไว้
โอเคทุเรียนเราก็ส่งทุเรียนออกไปต่าง
ประเทศนะคะส่งมังคุด
จะ
ไปต่างประเทศ
ก็ส่งผลไม้นะคะเราก็มีผลไม้อย่างหนึ่ง
เสียงกูโอเคไหมที่ส่งออกไปต่างประเทศนี่
ค่ะ
ก่อน
รู้สึกแบบอยากกิน
ใจเย็นๆใจเย็นๆ
ใจเย็นๆนะอ่าอันนี้คือเรียกว่าอะไรคะโพ
เรียมมะขามไห้ท่ามะขามนะมีมีกี่ชนิดคะ
มะขามเหรอเท่าที่เนี้ยรู้มี 2
ใช่ค่ะมีมะขามอะไรบ้างคะมะขามเปรี้ยว
มะขามเปรี้ยวเวลากินก็ไปเป็นยังไงก็จะก็
จะรู้สึกแบบน้ำลายไหลอ่ะโอ้
นี่เล่าเที่ยว
แล้วแต่อันนี้ 2 นะคะอันนี้ 2 มีมะขาม
หวานมะขามหวานกินแล้วรู้สึกรู้สึกอร่อย
หวานแนนค่าในรูปเนี่ยครูเรียมคิดว่าอัน
ไหนเป็นมะขามเปรี้ยวขา r  b  a
b
4 อันไหนเป็นมะขามเปรี้ยว
4 ค่ะ 4 ใช่ค่ะมาเองกับเมย์เนี่ยจะดู
แล้วเรารู้เลยเนาะมะขามหวานใช่ C น่ะเป็น
มะขามเปรี้ยวคู่เรียนชอบกินมะขามเปรี้ยว
หรือว่าคำหวานเดี๋ยวชอบกินมะขามหวานค่ะ
อ๋อชอบกินนะครับกว่ากู a นะชอบมาค่ะ
เปรียว
มะขามเปรี้ยวไม่ค่อยกินว่าเขาหวาน
ก็แปลว่าที่เอามะขามมาให้นักเรียนดูเนี่ย
จะบอกนักเรียนว่ามะขามเนี่ยกูอีกข้างตกใจ
เหมือนกันนะเป็นผลไม้ที่ส่งออกต่างประเทศ
ค่ะ
แล้วส่งเยอะมาก
แต่ตอนเนี้ยมีปัญหา
มีปัญหาอะไรคะ k
k ก่อนเช่นไปพูดถึงปัญหาเเละกูเรียนรู้
ไหมคะว่ามะขามเนี่ยอันนี้แผนที่ประเทศไทย
มะขามเนี่ยมีมากที่สุดที่จังหวัดอะไร
จังหวัดอะไรคะเพชร
คิดว่าเพชรบูรณ์
ใช่ค่ะที่นี่กับนักเรียน
จังหวัดเพชรบูรณ์นะคะจังหวัดเพชรบูรณ์
เป็นจังหวะที่ปลูกมะขามมานะคะมะขามที่ส่ง
ออกก็มีทั้งมะขามเปรี้ยวแล้วก็มะขามหวาน
Cat ก็จะไม่เหมือนกันนะครับที่นี่เนี่ย
ที่จังหวัดเพชรบูรณ์นะค่ะนักเรียนเขาก็จะ
มีตัวนี้นะเนี่ยเขาเรียกว่าลง
หลุมเป็นที่ไหนคะนี่เลยค่ะเนี่ยอันเนี้ย
เย็นลงก็คือคือเป็นเป็น
เขาเรียกอะไรเป็นโรงงานหรือเป็นโกดังอ่ะ
ค่ะที่เขาที่นี่เป็นออฟฟิศเลยนะคะเขาจะไป
ที่ที่ที่ฟาร์มของมะขามนะฮะเราเขาก็จะไป
ซื้อนะไปดูว่า a มะขามวันนี้เปรี้ยวหรือ
หวานอันนี้เป็นลงไทยนะครับเขาก็จะไปแล้ว
ก็มะขามว่าอยากชิมก่อนนะโอเคมะขามหวานอ่ะ
ซื้อทั้งหมด
เขาก็จะซื้อทั้งหมดแล้วเอามาเราก็ส่งไป
ให้บริษัท
เหมาะ
สำหรับแขกแล้วก็ส่งขายต่างประเทศก็จะเป็น
Clutch ต้องคัดเกรด A เกรด B เกรด C
size ยาวเท่าไหร่ปั้นเท่าไหร่นะคะแต่ว่า
เออถ้าอันเนี้ยถ้าเป็นที่ซื้อเอามะขามมา
รวมกันแบบนี้ก็เป็นลงมะขาม
ถ้าเอาทุเรียนมาใส่รวมกันก็เป็นลงทุเรียน
นะครับ
ก็คือเป็นบริษัทเป็นออฟฟิศที่ซื้อทุเรียน
มามามะขามหมาเราก็ส่งไปที่แพ็คแล้วก็ส่ง
ต่างประเทศส่งออกเขาเรียกว่าหลงนกนิส่ง
ต่างประเทศอย่างเดียวหรอคะหรือว่าขายใน
ประเทศไทยด้วยไหมประเทศค่ะส่งต่างประเทศ
อาจจะขายในไทยด้วยแต่ว่าเขาก็จะทำอ่าเขา
จะทำเพื่อที่จะต้องส่งไปขายที่ต่างประเทศ
มากกว่านะคะ
เนี่ยตอนนี้กูเรียมที่ประเทศไทยเนี่ยลง
ไทยมีปัญหามากๆ
มันคือปัญหาอะไรคะอย่างนี้ค่ะตรงนี้ได้
เนาะเอาตรงนี้เป็นฟาร์ม
เอาสีเขียวและกัน
อันนี้เป็นฟาร์มมะขาม
มะขามใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็อันนี้เป็นออฟฟิศลง
เป็นลงไทยค่ะ
คนที่หลงถ่ายน่ะ
เขาก็จะต้องไป
ไปคุยกับพี่ฟาร์ม
เราก็ขอซื้อสีขาว
ซื้อราคาแล้วก็ดูว่ามะขามมีเกรด A
B  4
นะก็ให้ราคาเท่าไหร่
แล้วก็พร้อมพอมะขามมีลูกโตๆก็เอาอ่าโอเค
เกรด B กี่กีบตัน1ตันเนี่ย 1 ตันเนี่ย
กี่กิโลคะคุณเหลี่ยมคุณตัน 1,000 กิโลค่ะ
1,000 กรัมก็จะบอกว่าหนึ่งพันกิโลกรัม
นี้ราคาเท่าไหร่เขาจะคุยเราก็จะมีมี
กระดาษเนาะ
นะฮะ cm
เป็นสัญญาแล้ว
ก็มีมะขามปั๊บที่ฟาร์มก็จะส่งมาที่ลง
ก็จะมีแบบเกรด A เกรด B เกรด C ถ้ารวมไก่
แต่ตอนเนี้ยที่บอกว่าลงแล้วลงเนี่ยก็จะ
ส่งให้
ส่งไปให้ลูกค้า
บ่เห็นไหมก็ได้มองเห็นค่ะส่งไปให้ลูกค้า
ที่ไหนคะพี่เอาก็ต่างประเทศหรอเบนอินเดีย
ให้ต่างประเทศ
ให้ต่างประเทศแล้วตอนนี้ที่มีปัญหาคือ
อะไรก็ไม่ลูกค้าเนี่ยลูกค้าจีนลูกค้า
อินเดียก็จะเข้ามาดูเข้ามาดูว่าลงคนเนี้ย
ทำงานยังไงโอเคไหมคอนแทคกับอันนี้โอเคไหม
ลูกค้ามาแล้วก็ดู
ใช่ค่ะนึงก็เห็นน่าจะดีลูกค้าจะเข้ามาดู
ดูที่
โรงงานดูที่โกดังแล้วอ้าอ๊อดทำงานมั้ย
เป็นปกติมีปัญหาอะไรคะนี่ปัญหาแต่ตอนนี้
เนี่ยลูกค้าอันนี้ลูกค้าใช่ไหมคนจีนคน
อินเดียน่ะไม่ไม่ซื้อกับลงไทยแล้ว
ลูกค้าซื้อกับฟาร์มมะขาม
ลูกลูกค้าบเปิดลงเองเขากดลงที่ประเทศไทย
ไม่เปิดที่ถ่ายรวยลูกค้านะมาแล้วก็ซื้อ
ทั้งหมดแล้วก็เอาไปประเทศตัวเอง
เอาเอา
พริกที่พี่คูเอเซอร์ที่ข่าวนะคะเป็นข้าว
เขาบอกว่าเอาไปนู่นเลยค่ะเอาไปประเทศจีน
เลย
ไม่รู้เอาไปได้ยังไงเยอะๆแต่ขับรถไปเลยนะ
คะไว้แล้วจะเอาออกไปแล้วก็ไปเก็บจะเก็บ
ไว้ที่ตัวเอง
แต่ว่าตอนนี้ที่ไทยน่ะหลงไทยไม่มีก็ต้อง
ไปซื้อที่จีน
เก็บจีนแล้วก็ไปเอาที่จีนมาใคร
ใช่เก็บเก็บที่ปีแล้วก็ต้องซื้อของเขา
แล้วก็เอามาเคลือบขายให้ส่งออกไปยุโรปส่ง
ออกไปเอามาลิกา
แปลเวลาไปเอามาปั๊บเนี่ย ka ลงของตีน่ะ
เขาเขาไม่แยกมะขามเปรี้ยวมะขามหวาน
มันรวมกันเลยนะเว้ย
ไอ้
เคมาต้องแยกแต่ว่าราคาเค้าจะถูกกว่าแล้ว
ที่นี้เนี่ยเวลาคนไทยขายใช่ไหมคนไทยขาย
ปกติคนไทยครับเกรด A เกรด B  A4 ค่า
ดอลล่าใช่ไหมคะค่ะอ่า
แต่ปรากฏว่าของจีนเขาขาย $3
ตามล่าเพราะว่าเขาไม่แยกเกตเองใช่ไหมงั้น
บริษัทที่ต่างประเทศก็ตอนนี้ก็ซื้อซื้อ
จากจีนมากกว่า
แล้วฟาร์มก็บอกฟาร์มเนี่ยก็ขายให้จีนมาก
กว่าเพราะว่าง่ายกว่ารวมแล้วขายเลยไม่
ต้องขัดเกรด
ตามความรู้สึกว่าได้เงินมากกว่าเข้าใจ
เงินให้ก่อนไงโคเรียมคือเข้ามาบอกอ่ะโอเค
นะ
อยากได้มะขามใช่มะอยากได้มากหากให้ฉัน
จ่ายเงินเลยเงินสด
เอาเงินแล้วก็ให้เลยแล้วก็เอามะขามไปขอ
โต๊ดจ่ายเงินให้ใช้เป็นเขตเลี้ยงอ่ะก็ไม่
ได้มะขามก็ต้องรอ
อ้าต้องจองไว้เลยอ่ะจองและมีมะขามไหม
อาเมย์โอเคฉันซื้อจ่ายเงินสดฝากว่าเก็บ
เก็บแล้วก็ให้ด้วยแล้วก็เอาเงินวันเลย
คือฟาร์มเขาก็คิดว่าเขาได้เงินเลยแล้วก็
ไม่ต้องไม่ต้องแยกเกรดไงแล้วก็เรียนรู้
ไหมคะว่าถ้าเกิดเป็นลงไปซื้อเขาจะจ่าย
เงินตอนไหน
เขาก็ต้องมีนักขามคัดเกรดมาแล้วก็เช็ค
คุณภาพก่อนแล้วก็จ่ายเงิน
มันมันไม่ได้ตอนนี้เลยมันไม่เหมือนกันนะ
คะก็เลยเป็นข่าวว่าเออตอนนี้ก็เลยมะขาม
คุณภาพมันก็เลยยหวานเปรี้ยวเค็มเอ้ยไม่
รู้
ไม่มี
โอ้ยลงไทยปวดหัวเนื้อ
หาออกปวดหัวมากแล้วแล้วมันก็ตอนนี้ต้อง
ซื้อแพงขึ้นมาแพงขึ้นเราก็เป็นปัญหาใน
ประเทศไทยของลงไทยร้องไทยตอนนี้บ่ๆทำยัง
ไงดีช่วยด้วย
ใครจะช่วยดี
ใช่เพราะว่ามีหลายๆร้องในประเทศไทยปิดไป
แล้วค่ะเปล่าเงียบเสร็จแล้วก็ล่าสุดและ
ครูเอ๋ซื้ออะไรนะกระเทียมโคเรียมมาก
กระเทียม
ธรรมดากระเทียมจากเชียงใหม่น่ะ 1
กิโลกรัมประมาณ
30-40 บาท
ถ้าใช่
ลบแต่ว่าตอนนี้นี้กูเอกก็โทรศัพท์ถาม
เพื่อนมีกระเทียมเล่นเพลง
กระเทียมไม่มีไม่รู้ใครเอาทั้งหมด
ร้องเอากระเทียมหมดแล้วก็อาจเป็นกระเทียม
ที่แบบถอนขึ้นมาแล้วเอาไปเลย
เหมือนว่าขามาโคเรียมคือมะขามที่ถ่ายน่ะ
แกเก็บออกมาปั๊บต้องเอาไปให้มีพระอาทิตย์
ใช่ไหมมีพระอาทิตย์
พระอาทิตย์สีแดงเนาะ
อาทิตย์
อาทิตย์ให้ร้อนๆนะคะลำร้อนๆร้อนก่อนมะขาม
แช่แห้งโอเคค่ะขายกล่าวว่าถ้าเป็นลงจีนมา
ไม่เป็นไรเก็บเอาไปเลยไม่ต้องให้แม่
ใช้ไม่ต้องกระเทียมเหมือนกันนะหมู
กระเทียมเนี่ยก็ไม่ต้องแห้งเอาไปเลย
หน้าแต่ว่าถ้าคนไทยซื้อเนี่ยเขาจะต้องเอา
กระเทียมมามารับหน้าที่นี่ใช่ไหมคะมาร์ค
แล้วก็กระเทียมกระเทียมแล้วก็โดนแดดผัก
กระเทียมกระเทียมเราเรียกกระเทียมสดถึงมา
สีเขียวก็แค่แห้งแห้งแห้งเป็นสีสีน้ำตาล
สีชมพูสีน้ำตาลหายที่ไหนเป็นสี
สีออกส้มๆน้ำตาล
มีไหม
มันจะออกเป็นสีหน้า
สีน้ำตาลน้ำตาลรู้สึกกระเทียม
กระเทียมแห้งแต่แต่ว่าอันนี้คือเวลาร้าน
ขายคนไทยต้องทำแบบนี้แต่ถ้าแบบลงตีนมาก็
ไม่เป็นไรสดเอาไปเลย
คนทำฟาร์มก็รู้สึกสบายใช่ไหมคะสบายก็ขาย
ตอนนี้คิดว่าไม่ใช่แค่ลงแล้วนะที่มีปัญหา
คนไทยกำลังจะมีปัญหาเพราะไม่มีกระเทียม
กินใช่กระเทียมแพงขึ้นนะค่ะโดนซื้อไปหมด
แล้วกระเทียมน่ะมันดีที่รักก็เลยแบบตอน
นี้ก็เลยแบบมีปัญหาว่ากๆเรื่องโดนโดนซื้อ
ทุกอย่างจะใคร
คนไทยก็ต้องปลูกเองค่ะตอนนี้
พี่ก็กรูเองนะคะพี่คอนโด
นิดหน่อยนิดหน่อย
อันนี้เป็นเป็นปัญหาเรื่องการส่งออกใน
ประเทศไทยอาจเปลี่ยนถ่าย
ก็
เป็นปัญหาเรื่องอ่ะเป็นปัญหาของการส่งของ
ออกที่เป็นอ่ะผลไม้นะผลไม้การส่งกลไม้ออก
ในประเทศไทยตอนนี้มีปัญหามากเพราะว่าอ่ะ
ลงไทยน่ะแข่งกับลงแต่งประเทศไม่ได้
ร้องต่างประเทศเข้ามาซื้อซื้อตรงละเอาออก
ไปเลย
แล้วก็ไม่ได้เปิดเป็นบริษัทในไทยด้วยนะ
ชื่อไม่ได้จ่ายอะไรให้ลูกไก่ไม่ได้จ่าย
แท็กอะไรเลยใช่งูตอนนี้
ช่วยด้วยลงท้ายบอกช่วยด้วย
เราก็ไม่รู้จะทำยังไงล่ะคะก็แค่เอามาคุย
คุยคุยกันให้เรียงให้เปลี่ยนสั่ง
ให้นักเรียนฟังอีกทีถ้านักเรียนซื้อ
มะขามมาเอกทำไมมะขามไทยตอนนี้ไม่อร่อยก็
ต้องดูนะคะก็ 3 ไทยจริงๆมั้ย
มะขามไทยจริงแต่ไม่ได้คัดเกรดอาจจะเอามา
รวมกันนะคะก็ต้องอยู่ดีๆ
โอเคค่ะวันนี้นะคะนักเรียนก็รู้จัก
ข่าวในประเทศไทยเกี่ยวกับลงในประเทศไทยก็
คือโรงงานที่ใหญ่ๆที่เก็บผลไม้สวยผลไม้มา
สำหรับส่งออกนะคะใช่แล้ว
โอเควันนี้หน้าใช่ไหมปวดหัวหน้ามีปัญหาก็
จะเริ่มปวดหัว
ที่คลีนิเราจะคุยกันเรื่องอะไรเดียวรอดู
ในคลิปหน้า
ใช่ค่ะโอเคค่ะงั้นคลิปนี้คุณเอกกับคน
เดียวไปก่อนนะคะใช่ค่ะจะนอนแล้วค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะคุณเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบายนี้ค่ะนักเรียนได้บ้าง
อ่ะ